[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen in ein norbert lehmann ist
auch dabei für den sport talk show
moderator von mir heute gab es
erklärungen des bundeskanzlers
scholz verteidigt seinen ukraine kurs im
zdf waren der kanzler vor und besonnenem
handeln
jede entscheidung müsse sorgfältig
abgewogen
streit über öl embargo gegen russland
deutschland erklärt sich jetzt dazu
bereit doch ungarn und die slowakei
blockieren weitere eu sanktionen
und absturz der adler group der
immobilieninvestor meldet einen
milliarden-verlust die aktien gehen auf
talfahrt
gutes handeln in der ukraine krise das
bescheinigten dem bundeskanzler im
politbarometer im märz noch 72 prozent
der befragten aktuell sind es noch 49
olaf scholz steht unter druck die einen
werfen ihm mangelnde führung und
zögerlichkeit vor die anderen
kriegstreiberei heute stand scholz in
unserem hauptstadtstudio rede und
antwort lars bohnsack und andreas
huppert waren dabei
der bundeskanzler zum interview im zdf
hauptstadtstudio was nun herr schulz
nach über zwei monaten krieg in der
ukraine
lange hatte der bundeskanzler gezögert
vor allem beim thema lieferung von
schweren waffen und dafür kritik
geerntet nicht nur von der opposition
sondern auch aus den eigenen reihen ich
habe immer schnell entschieden zusammen
mit allen anderen mich mit den
verbündeten abgestimmt aber mein kurs
ist schon dass wir besonnen und mit
klarem verstand handel der russische
angriffskrieg auf die ukraine nicht nur
eine militärische herausforderung
sondern auch eine wirtschaftliche ein
öl-embargo wie ist die außenministerin
gestern angekündigt hat wird es so
schnell wohl nicht geben so finden
können allmählich aus der kohle raus wir
können etwas schneller auf öl verzichten
wir wissen aber um die noch ungelösten
probleme die es bei raffinerien im osten
deutschlands gebe und die sind auch noch
nicht gelöst so gelöst die frage der
finanzierung der bundeswehr dafür will
die ampel ein 100 milliarden sonderfall
auflegen deswegen aber abstriche beim
sozialen zu machen lehnt der kanzler
entschieden ab es geht auch darum dass
wir natürlich in einer zeit in der so
viele herausforderungen auf uns zukommen
auch die gesellschaft zusammenhalten
müssen und das wollen wir einen baldigen
besuch in der ukraine wie von vielen
gefordert kann sich olaf scholz momentan
nicht vorstellen das ist doch immerhin
ein ganz bemerkenswerter vorgang ist
dass der präsident der bundesrepublik
deutschland damit eine mehrheit wie
glaube ich niemand vor ihm in der
bundesversammlung wenige wochen vorher
für eine zweite amtszeit nominiert
worden ist ausgeladen worden ist das
steht dem immer noch entgegen da sind
der sache das steht der sache im weg der
ukraine krieg fordert die
bundesregierung an vielen fronten
dafür aber seinen regierungsstil ändern
will der bundeskanzler nicht das machte
das interview noch mal deutlich
theo koll war bei der aufzeichnung in
berlin dabei welchen eindruck macht der
kanzler auch sie nun das war heute ein
urlaubs zumindest engagierter wirkte als
es sonst seine tonalität und gestik ist
wir leben ja ganz offensichtlich
natürlich in maßen eine neue
kommunikationsstrategie der kanzler gibt
verstärkt zeitungs und auch
fernsehinterviews erklärt stärker und
häufiger seine politik bisher galt bei
scholz ja eher die eiserne regel der
britischen queen sich niemals beschweren
sich niemals rechtfertigen vor allem
aber der letzte teil sich nicht zu
rechtfertigen der ist die mit diesen
kriegszeiten politisch eher auf die füße
gefallen die vorwürfe zu leise und zu
wenig präsent zu sein die wurden ja
zuletzt immer massiver auch aus der
ampel auch aus seiner eigenen partei
selbst wenn er sich äußere verstehe man
ihn manchmal kaum und auch wenn eine
reihe anderer länder der ukraine nicht
mehr oder schneller geholfen haben war
es ja nicht zuletzt die stolze
zurückhaltung kommunikative
zurückhaltung die vor allem die
bundesrepublik zu einem leichten ziel
von kritik gemacht hat jetzt gilt also
offensichtlich mehr präsenz auf der
politischen bühne so eine art scholz im
scheinwerfer die einschätzung unserer
hauptstadtkorrespondenten dankeschön
theo koll
was nun herr scholz die ganze sendung
gibt es gleich nach uns um 19 uhr 20 und
natürlich jederzeit in der zdf- heute-
app
das cdu-chef märz nach kiew reisen will
stößt auf unterschiedliche resonanz für
die einen ist es ein wichtiges zeichen
der solidarität
andere werten ist als versucht den
kanzler unter druck zu setzen und bei
den anstehenden landtagswahlen zu
punkten heute äußerte sich friedrich
merz erstmals persönlich zu seinen
reiseplänen dort der vater berichtet
friedrich merz begrüsst zur gemeinsamen
cdu/csu präsidiumsklausur in köln denn
in nordrhein westfalen sind zwei wochen
landtagswahlen es sind wahlkampfzeiten
aber seine ukraine reise sei schon seit
langem geplant betont merz die einladung
des parlaments in kiew habe er schon vor
kriegsbeginn erhalten
und da ich in den letzten wochen
keinerlei anzeichen dafür gesehen habe
dass der bundeskanzler eine solche reise
plant habe ich keinerlei veranlassung
mehr gesehen darauf zu warten dass ich
diese einladung annehmen das hat nicht
die bundesregierung zu beurteilen oder
gar zu kommentieren das ist meine
entscheidung auch die spd-spitze ist im
nordrhein westfälischen wahlkampf
unterwegs spd-chef klingbeil warnt davor
den ukraine krieg parteipolitisch zu
vereinnahmen wenn er merz diese reise
nutzt um sich wieder parteipolitisch zu
inszenieren wieder den kleinkarierten
kleinteiligen streit zu suchen dann
begeht er einen großen fehler und sendet
damit auch schwierige zeichnens ausland
dass man in dieser frage gespalten und
zerstritten ist die fdp warnt merz
ebenfalls den kiew besuch zu
instrumentalisieren
wenn es parteipolitisch motiviert ist
was ich nicht hoffe
dann sozusagen um den kanzler vor sich
herzutreiben was ich hoffe er macht das
nicht deswegen wenn es aber der sache
als solches dienst dann wünsche ich gute
reise unterstützung bekommt märz aus den
eigenen reihen in köln begrüßten sie in
union sein
zum thema energie abhängigkeit und
sicherheit da geht es jetzt vor allem um
ein europäisches öl-embargo gegen
russland deutschland das bisher bremste
zeigt sich jetzt bereit dafür nach
angaben des wirtschaftsministeriums
macht russisches öl aktuell nur noch
zwölf prozent des deutschen verbrauchs
aus doch es gibt noch widerstand in der
eu ungarn und die slowakei etwa sind
stark abhängig von den lieferungen über
die beratungen der energieminister
florian neumann aus brüssel
der vizekanzler kommt mit neuer
deutscher position nach brüssel seine
regierung ist nun offen für ein öl
embargo auch wenn das teuer werden
könnte für uns alle wir werden höhere
inflation höhere energiepreise und eine
belastung der wirtschaft haben und wir
sind als europäerinnen und europäer
bereit die zu tragen um der ukraine zu
helfen europa ringt ob es nach kohle nun
schrittweise auch auf russisches öl
verzichtet die zahl der befürworter
wuchs zuletzt quasi täglich österreich
ist bereit einen bagger konsequent
mitzutragen wenn die kommission und die
mitgliedstaaten sich dafür entscheiden
vor allem zwei länder aber sind noch
nicht so weit die slowakei und ungarn
beide stark abhängig von russischem öl
im ungarischen fernsehen droht der
kanzleramtsminister mit einer blockade
um es klar und deutlich zu sagen wir
werden sanktionen im hinblick auf öl und
gas niemals unterstützen in brüssel aber
erleben sie die regierung offenbar
anders
ungarn hat sich wie alle europäischen
staaten konzept eve gezeigt alle
mitgliedsstaaten zeigen ein gespür für
die aktuelle situation hier eine große
gemeinsame verantwortung erfordert sie
gegen konrad ag kollektiv bis mittwoch
will die eu kommission einen vorschlag
für das neue sanktionspaket vorliegen
einem ölembargo müssten alle
mitgliedsstaaten zustimmen um ungarn und
die slowakei ins boot zu holen denkt man
in brüssel über besonders lange
übergangsfristen und ausnahmen für beide
länder nach doch auch deutschland will
nicht komplett von heute auf morgen auf
russisches öl verzichten ein
vollständiges embargo dürfte es daher
frühestens im herbst geben
russlands außenminister lavrov hat mit
einem interview international empörung
ausgelöst
darauf angesprochen dass der ukrainische
präsident seelands jedoch jude sei also
in kiew keine nazis am werk sein könnten
hatte la worauf gesagt auch adolf hitler
habe jüdisches blut gehabt das heißt gar
nichts israel kritisierte labeouf schaaf
der antisemitismus beauftragte der
bundesregierung klein sagte sabrow
verdreht zynisch opfer und täter der
geschichte und der gegenwart
in der ukraine in mario pohl wächst die
hoffnung noch mehr menschen evakuieren
zu können aus dem stahlwerk und auch aus
der völlig zerstörten stadt groß ist die
erleichterung bei denen die der hölle
von mario pohl entkommen sind nina
kurschilgen
das erste mal tageslicht nach mehr als
zwei monaten leben unter der erde
jetzt ist alles gut der bus ist nicht
mehr weit eine extrem harte zeit war es
vor dutzende von ihnen ich kann es
einfach nicht glauben nach so langer
zeit in der dunkelheit jetzt müssen wir
nicht mehr mit der taschenlampe auf die
toilette gehen wir dachten es sei noch
für zwei drei tage und jetzt waren wir
mehr als neun wochen da unten
ich habe kein zuhause mehr es wurde ja
permanent bombardiert
mehr als 125 menschen haben es schon
raus geschafft laut präsident selensky
auch durch die erste echte waffe nur
dort sie wurden bei der gemeinsamen
aktion vom roten kreuz und den vereinten
nationen vom stahlwerk mit bussen erst
einmal nach basim ende gebracht dann
weiter ins ukrainische kontrollierte
favorit er heute stockt er offenbar die
evakuierung die busse seien vom
provisorischen zeltlager nicht zurück am
berg angekommen warum unklar
andernorts gehen die gefechte
unvermindert weiter die russische seite
zeigt diese bilder 27 ziele sollen bei
luft- und raketenangriffen beschossen
worden seien
die ukraine wiederum meldet sie habe
zwei russische patrouillenboote versenkt
wenn man sich die militärische lage
ansieht merkt man dass es zwar sehr
starke russische angriffe gibt im
donbass im osten die aber trotzdem nicht
so richtig vorankommen es gab sogar
kleine gewinne von ukrainischer seite um
aktiv also insgesamt entsteht das bild
das sich da nicht sehr groß was bewegt
weder in seiten wieder für russland noch
für die ukraine es ist eher so ein
stillstand szenario ein stillstand
szenario aus politischer sicht für die
menschen in den betroffenen gebieten
bleibt es eine große tragödie
der ukraine krieg ist auch thema beim
besuch des indischen premiers narendra
modi in berlin indien lehnt es ab sich
an sanktionen gegen russland zu
beteiligen ist bezieht einen großteil
seiner rüstung von dort bei dem treffen
heute gab es da wohl keine wesentliche
annäherung aber deutschland und indien
wollen beim klimaschutz enger
zusammenarbeiten zum beispiel bei der
zukunftstechnologie wasserstoff
deutschland fördert die zusammenarbeit
mit zehn milliarden euro
die eu geht erneut gegen apple vor nach
vorläufigen ermittlungen verstößt der
us-konzern gegen europäisches
wettbewerbsrecht
der vorwurf diesmal apple verwehre der
konkurrenz den zugang zu seiner
technologie für kontaktloses bezahlen
mit iphones und das zugunsten seiner
eigenen lösung apple vor allem banken
sehen sich benachteiligt bleibt die eu
bei ihrer einschätzung könnte das eine
hohe strafzahlung für apple bedeuten
gegen das unternehmen läuft bereits ein
anderes eben verfahren große aufregung
heute in der finanzwelt der börsenwert
des immobilienkonzerns ag mit sitz in
luxemburg stürzt regelrecht ab der
verdacht geschäfte und jüngste bilanzen
sollen teils so undurchsichtig sein dass
die beauftragten wirtschaftsprüfer von
kpmg alarm gaben und sich weigerten
einen geschäftsbericht abzusegnen ein
ziemlich seltener vorgang adler ist in
deutschland an in projekten beteiligt
fragen wir nach bei valerie haller an
der börse was ist da passiert ja
möglicherweise ein neuer bilanzskandal
also die adler group hat am samstag auf
den allerletzten drücker ihren
jahresabschluss 20 21 veröffentlicht mit
einem gewaltigen verlust von über einer
milliarde euro durch anleger dürften
nicht allzu viel darauf geben denn die
wirtschaftsprüfer von kpmg verweigern
der bilanz das prüfsiegel begründung
wichtige informationen seien nicht
zugänglich gemacht worden darunter
offenbar tausende von e mails ein schock
für anleger die aktie verliert 1 29
prozent ernüchternd an dem fall ist dass
nicht die wirtschaftsprüfer den stein
ins rollen gebracht haben sondern ein
externer kritiker der auch schon beim
aufdecken des wirecard skandals eine
entscheidende rolle gespielt hat und
wieder einmal fragt man sich ob die
prüfer nicht schon viel früher diesen
zweifeln hätten nachgehen müssen
dankeschön valerie haller aus frankfurt
für muslime ist eine zeit der
entbehrungen wieder vorbei der
fastenmonat ramadan geht zu ende
weltweit feiern dass viele millionen
gläubige mit gebeten etwa in jerusalem
dort versammelten sich zehntausende vor
der al aksa moschee
in der türkei wo das fastenbrechen
zuckerfest genannt wird gab es weniger
andrang bei den händlern als sonst vor
allem wegen der gestiegenen
lebensmittelpreise
und jetzt sind wir beim fußball norbert
zwei bundesligaspieler heute abend ja
mit zwei champions league aspiranten
leipzig spielt in gladbach und
leverkusen die bayer-elf die empfängt
die eintracht die ist als
tabellenzehnter ja jenseits von gut und
böse frankfurt will sich heute abend
sogar schonend für die europa league in
drei tagen
seit 30.000 eintracht fans den sieg in
barcelona erlebten ist klar an der
ausklingenden bundesliga-saison sinn
dieser anhänger wie wohl auch eintracht
spieler nicht mehr interessiert ob die
leverkusener diese konstellation heute
zu solchen treffern nutzen ist ihnen
egal hauptsache frankfurt trumpfte am
donnerstag noch einmal gegen west ham
auf und verteidigte ihn 21 vor
eintrachts trainer sieht das
offensichtlich genauso und spricht das
auch ganz offen aus
auch jetzt nicht um den heißen brei
reden dass das donnerstagsspiel das
rückspiel gegen west in die oberste
priorität hat bei uns jetzt denn
schließlich wollen sie am donnerstag
noch ausgelassener feiern als vergangene
woche in london
und die höhepunkte der beiden
begegnungen heute abend und überhaupt
alle tore des 32 spieltags zu sehen bei
zdf heute.de und in der zdf- heute- app
wochenlang war über seinen wechsel zum
bvb spekuliert worden jetzt ist
offiziell freiburgs verteidiger niko
schlotterbeck spielt nächste saison in
dortmund der 22 jährige nationalspieler
erhält dort einen fünfjahresvertrag
spätestens nach dem gewinn der u 21 em
im letzten jahr hat nico schlotterbeck
auf sich aufmerksam gemacht und nach
seinen ersten beiden länderspielen ende
märz hatten ihn auch andere vereine auf
ihrer liste bei borussia dortmund soll
er mithelfen die über große menge an
gegentoren zu verhindern unterstützt in
der neuen spielzeit auch vom noch bayern
niklas süle
dass nico schlotterbeck auch in des
gegners hälfte seiner akzente setzt
gibt's für dortmund noch obendrauf
die ablösesumme soll bei etwas über 20
millionen euro liegen beachtlich
sonnenuntergänge haben ja immer viel
charme der jetzt in chile aber ganz
besonders weil der beobachter genau zur
richtigen zeit am richtigen ort stand
während einer teil sonnenfinsternis
findet ihr den magischen moment ein als
der feuerball vom mond angeknabbert ganz
langsam ins meer eintauchte phänomenal
schön
auch bei uns zeigt sich die sonne
vielleicht nicht ganz so schön das
wetter bleibt warum aber erneut mit
gewittern mehr dazu hat gleich aus dem
verlies christian sievers begrüßt sie um
viertel vor zehn im heute journal
danke für ihr interesse einen schönen
abend noch und bis morgen wenn sie mögen
[Musik]
schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter heute abend gibt
es noch im süden letzte schauer die
lasse allmählich nach in den frühstunden
kommt mit einer kaltfront im norden neu
bewölkung auf und regen ist dabei bei
temperaturen von ein bis neun grad das
ist die temperaturspanne und für morgen
vormittag gibt es im norden mit der
kaltfront kompakte wolken und regen
sonst ist es aber trocken mit sonnigen
abschnitten zum nachmittag brodelt es im
süden gießen dann schauer und gewitter
dabei die dann nach norden hinaus
wachsen sonst aber bleibt es trocken bei
höchsten temperaturen von 12 bis 14 grad
im norden und 20 bis 21 grad im
südwesten damit ein schöner abend